in December of last year doctors in
Wuhan China had a mystery on their hands
people in the region were coming down
with an unusual pneumonia it's cold and
flu season but these people didn't have
either doctors quickly realized it might
be something entirely new medical
nightmare the corona virus outbreak
never seen before corona virus the
number of confirmed cases in China keeps
soaring already 45 cases 200 cases there
more than 6,000 confirmed cases but so
far this outbreak has gone differently
from others in the past thanks to the
latest in biotechnology scientists have
been able to unravel the mystery at
remarkable speed they're revealing the
biology of the new virus more quickly
than ever before and they're hoping it's
fast enough to help drive back the
disease outbreak Chinese officials told
the World Health Organization that had
an outbreak of some kind of virus on
December 31st by January 7th Chinese
scientists figured out that the virus
was a corona virus that's from the same
family of virus as SARS which emerged in
China in 2002 and MERS which infected
people in the Middle East in 2012 the
next step in understanding the new virus
was sequencing its genome figuring out
the unique order of nucleotides genetic
building blocks that make it out the new
coronavirus genome looks like this it's
just under 30 thousand bases long the
corona virus is made of a type of genic
material called RNA but scientists
convert it to the more recognizable DNA
to make it easier to study that's what
you're seeing here by January 13th less
than a week after it was identified
scientists in Shanghai had mapped out
the entire genetic sequence of a virus
sample collected from a patient
comparable with the SARS virus which
started infecting people in November
2002 it took until April 2003 before
that virus was sequenced in its entirety
and at this point we don't just have one
genetic sequence for the new corona
virus scientists have collected and
sequence nearly two dozen samples of the
virus collected from different patients
researchers say the speed has been
unprecedented a lot of important things
become possible once experts have this
full sequence of the virus notably that
blueprint can end up in a place like
this I mean this this is exact typical
although we get its a bunch of AC G and
T and force on a machine we can print
anything so if you want hemoglobin today
we can print even if you want chicken
DNA if you want corona virus DNA we can
do it
twist bioscience is a biotech company in
South San Francisco that builds custom
DNA to order as the corona virus
outbreak progresses scientists around
the world are turning to companies like
twists to build copies of viral genes
for urgent study and they're sending in
lots of orders we expected that there
will be a number of demands for violence
of the corona virus to help in in that
discovery of drugs vaccines and
diagnostic kits and whatever comes from
the web tonight
we will stop making tomorrow
custom-built DNA has been around since
the 1980s but the technology has gotten
dramatically cheaper and easier since
then so researchers today have a lot
more DNA at their disposal than they did
during the SARS or MERS outbreak should
go back to 2000 it would take $10 for
make one base of DNA in 2010 it would
make $1 so ten times more and today it's
nine cents per base so again ten times
more that's important because this kind
of research requires a lot of trial and
error so the more copies of a gene
scientists have the better so it's
biology and in biology it almost never
works on the first time you have to take
a lot of shots angles to to get there we
give people the opportunity to
take more shots angles faster now that's
way they can get to that answer faster
there's a few things scientists do with
this genetic material it can help create
tests to screen patients for the virus
it can help researchers understand how
the virus works
and what it does to cells in the body
and crucially it could be used in the
development of vaccines one important
note even though companies like twist
are churning out copies of the corona
virus genome there's no concern they'll
accidentally start an epidemic they're
not actually making the virus I think
one thing that people should remember is
that nature is the biggest bioterrorist
you know nature wants to kill you and no
that's what happens with the corona
virus so the virus is out there the
sequence is out there so we are not
creating more virus we're making
fragrance of the virus - researcher in
order to enable them to find tools to
detect it and tools to fight it
the coronavirus is still a fast
developing public health crisis it'll be
a while before we fully understand its
health impact and longer still before
there are treatments or vaccines
available to fight it but thanks to the
progress in DNA tech we have a greater
Head Start than ever before
thanks so much for watching if you're
interested in learning more about the
corona virus check out the verge comm
for the latest news on the ongoing
outbreak